E aí
[Música]
e
se formos da a definição correta do que
aconteceu em Mariana e se repetiu em
Brumadinho é que foi crime foram
Duzentos e setenta e duas vítimas fatais
em Brumadinho e 20 em Mariana eu incluo
aqui também os abortos que aconteceram
nesse processo com rompimento
duas mulheres perderam as crianças que
estavam esperando
e parecem números mas não são por trás
dessas desses números né que muitos de
Vocês ouviram pela mídia existem
histórias de resistência existem
histórias e memórias e
Olá eu sou mineira Eu Vim de Minas
Gerais eu nasci no estado cercado de
muitas montanhas de muitas cachoeiras eu
vivi um sonho eu tinha muita vontade de
andar naquele trem e eu colorir ia na
escola de forma Quase que lúdica
sonhando que algum dia eu pudesse andar
naqueles vagões
ela só um sonho
Ah e eu não sabia que ao redor das
minhas das cidades por onde eu vivi né
em Minas Gerais é ali tinha minério de
ferro naquelas montanhas e aquele
minério de ferro importava ao mundo
inteiro o meu estado é o estado que mais
produz minério de ferro em Minas Gerais
no Brasil e no mundo nós somos
responsáveis por todo o minério de ferro
que sai praticamente do Brasil e aí eu
fui entender a partir do rompimento de
barragem O que que significa a vão morar
nesse estado o que significavam aquelas
montanhas que eu via de forma Quase que
romantizada no meu estado foi nesse dia
cinco de novembro de 2015 que eu comecei
a entender quem eu era de verdade o que
que era ser Mineiro o que que era
exportar ao mundo inteiro as nossas
maiores riquezas aquele trem que levava
ao mar o nosso minério de ferro vou e
sempre vazio e nada ficava nas
comunidades só o empobrecimento
a partir da minha indignação com a
imprensa com a mídia que tratava e
continua tratando esses crimes como
tragédia como incidente como algo que
pode acontecer naturalmente na vida de
qualquer pessoa
Aquilo me ignorou não só me ignorou a
forma de tratar um crime mas como
tratava as pessoas como cuidava das
histórias dessas pessoas que na verdade
não existe cuidado não existe história
existe memória existe lucro existe uma
importância muito grande em dar atenção
ao que de fato gera para a economia
mundial porque no nosso estado não nos
era muito geram mortes gera sofrimento
já dá um descontentamento hoje mineira
Oi e a partir dessa indignação com a
imprensa com a mídia eu comecei a me
movimentar eu sou fotógrafo eu não vim
aqui para contar uma história pessoal eu
vim contar a história de quem eu virei
Depois desses 4 anos já fazem 4 anos o
primeiro rompimento que eu vivi e a
partir daí eu comecei aquele contar as
histórias das pessoas que viviam no meu
estado e que passaram sofrer com esses
rompimentos mas muito antes desses
rompimentos acontecer em outros
incidentes já tinham acontecido outros
crimes já tinham acontecido e eu queria
contar essas histórias Queria poder
fazer através do meu trabalho história
dessas pessoas que também são as minhas
histórias eu não sou uma pessoa atingida
diretamente porque eu não perdi minha
casa Eu não perdi minha família eu não
pedi as minhas histórias e minha terra
mas eu perdi parte de mim naqueles dias
que eu vivi de forma muito intensa
cobrindo aquelas duas tragédias né Oi
Adriana contra o Brumadinho E aí eu
trago para vocês a primeira história que
a história dos loucos por bentham que
são pessoas que vivem ainda frequentam o
território de Bento Rodrigues que é uma
primeira comunidade atingida com
rompimento em Mariana essas pessoas
continuam indo a esse território fazendo
a luta através da cultura através da
história através da religiosidade das
manifestações populares elas continuam
frequentando esse território porque para
elas ali não estão enterrados casas não
estão enterrados só terras ali enterrado
histórias memórias e elas tentam e lutam
muito para manter esse território
Impacto mas hoje em Minas Gerais o que
esta Marco quer é desapropriadas
terrenos dessa comunidade é tirar a vida
do que restou ali que são essas memórias
e afectos que essas pessoas carregam e
vão carregar ao longo de toda uma vida e
para elas a vida parou de 15 de novembro
de 2015 e elas continuam no território
Resistindo lutando não só pelos que
foram mas pelos que ainda permanecem
vivos pelos que ainda querem permanecer
de forma tradicional nessas comunidades
outra história são das Mães de
Brumadinho são mulheres que perderam
seus filhos seus maridos seus irmãos
perderam seus homens para aquela
tragédia que eles chamam de tagédia que
eu chamo crime no dia vinte e cinco de
Janeiro de 2019 Já faz quase um ano que
aconteceu mas elas continuam lutando
Resistindo e brigando com as mineradoras
para que se faça Justiça mas que parem
essa forma de fazer mineração que mata
que destrói a comunidades e quando eu
digo de destruir Eu não falo só de
destruir com aquela lama que eles chamam
de lama que parece é mas na terra
rejeito tóxico de mineração são inúmeros
os metais que tem ali presente naquele
rejeito que contaminam as comunidades E
essas mulheres se reúnem todo dia 25 no
monumento principal da cidade para dizer
que elas estão vivas e que elas vão
fazer justiça por esses filhos que elas
perderam elas são exemplos de
resistência e de luta por que tiveram
que sair do luto para fazer luta para
mostrar para outras cidades outras
comunidades de que a gente tem que lutar
pelo território onde a gente vive não só
pegar onde a gente vive mas pelos outros
territórios que estão hoje em ameaça os
Pataxós que fazem a resistência não Só
porque foram atingidos no Rio Paraopeba
e perderam um parente os indígenas
eles tratam tanto Rio quanto as
montanhas como parentes e nós deveríamos
tratar dessa mesma forma
É depende dessa água porque essa água
que chega na nossa casa às vezes a gente
se quer essa é a origem daquilo que
chega para nós de forma que a gente não
pensa mas são essas pessoas que estão
lutando Resistindo
a519 anos o nosso território para que
nós continuamos vivos para que nós
continuamos tendo a nossa água de forma
muito confortável nas nossas casas e
hoje não só perderam rio mas também
fazem uma luta por demarcação de suas
terras eles querem permanecer nessa
terra por mais que eles saibam que
aquele rio tá morto assim como o
Paraopeba está morto o Rio Doce está
morto e não existe reparação não tem
como voltar atrás nós matamos dois rios
dois ecossistemas e não matamos só o rio
matamos um várias espécies de animais
vai estamos várias formas de vida e que
não tem mais volta
a outra história que eu quero trazer é
sobre os sem-terra quilombolas que
também ocupam essas terras próximas a
Brumadinho
eles também foram atingidos também estão
lutando pela sobrevivência estão lutando
para serem reconhecidos como atingidos e
nem isso eles têm isso eu chamo de
racismo ambiental existem vários estudos
que dizem que essas empresas com essas
mineradores ela só se instalam nos
lugares onde as populações são mais
vulneráveis
outra história e que muitos de vocês
Talvez tenham ouvido é sobre o
terrorismo de barragem que fizeram em
Barão de Cocais que é uma outra cidade
dessa região da mineração e lá em Barão
de Cocais
eles apropriaram 600 pessoas por
enquanto nos apropriaram Por enquanto só
evacuaram essas pessoas e levaram para
Cidade só que o que eles querem de fato
nessas terras essas populações estão
denunciando em
é uma área de interesse na mineradora
Depois desses dois crimes que ficaram
conhecidos internacionalmente
bindomatic foi conhecido né mundialmente
com o maior acidente de trabalho e o que
eles querem fazer nessa terra é minerar
também E aí eu conheci o seu chico seu
Chico pãozinho mexeu muito comigo porque
ele é um morador que ou é que sofreu
tentativa de evacuação mas Ele resistiu
ele não aceitou sai do seu território
porque ele sabia que era importante
permanecer ali e fazer a luta pelo que
ele achava mais importante um dia
conversando com seu Chico ele disse
assim para mim menina Será que a
mineradora sabe que ali tem várias
espécies de orquídea Elas são tão bonita
será que ele se importam e passar o com
caminhão em cima delas e aí eu fiquei
com aquele pensar mas tem pensei mas
porque as orquídeas sabe e aquilo mexeu
comigo de uma forma porque algo tão
simples mas é simbólico porque o meu avô
também Oi e ele também tem esse modo
simples de vida e ele não quer abrir mão
da terra dele ele não quer sair dali
Porque ele disse que se ele for para
Cidade ele morre e morre mesmo essas
pessoas não sabem viver de outra forma e
ele se diz Guardião da terra ele fala
daqui eu não saio eu sou um desses
Guardiões que tá cuidando dessa água e
foi nesse Território que eu bebi uma das
águas mais puras que eu já bebi na minha
vida é o seu Chico que é responsável
pela que a água em Barão de Cocais chega
e limpa porque ele tá ali próximo da
Mata Atlântica e um dos biomas mais
atingidos e mais devastados no nosso
país
é essa Dona rosemira esposa do seu Chico
e as mulheres também sofrem
silenciamento nesse território por causa
do machismo que é muito presente nessas
comunidades Mas ela disse muita coisa
para mim também todas as pessoas me
fazem entender quem eu sou hoje e pelo
que eu luto e esse é o clima dessa
cidades que vivem da mineração e elas
acabam economicamente com essa cidades
que quando ela chegam elas dão emprego
mas elas tiram a vida das pessoas elas
tiram a dignidade que é o que tem de
mais justo Oi e aí uma outra história
quer ir no litoral capixaba no Espírito
Santo as pessoas lutam para serem
reconhecidas Porque apesar de ter
acontecido um rompimento lá em Minas
Gerais isso não quer dizer que isso não
tem afetado a tantas outras comunidades
e tantos outros cidades até chegar no
litoral Inclusive essa lama chegou até a
Bahia mas isso foi silenciado também e
essas pessoas lutam pela sobrevivência
porque eles são catadores pescadores e
viviam da Pesca e essas pessoas hoje
elas lutam para se manterem vivas Porque
toda a água está contaminada E durante
dois anos essas pessoas passarão bebendo
essa água direto do Rio e todas as
pessoas estão contaminadas
e quando eu digo que existe um
sofrimento por esse morar em área de
mineração eu não digo só desse
rompimento mais do que vem desse minério
que está poluindo não só a água o solo o
ar é isso chega para as pessoas e elas
estão adoecendo os índices de suicídio
aumentaram as mortes aumentaram não tem
mais como contabilizar quantas pessoas
estão morrendo com essas tragédias que a
gente está permitindo que aconteça
porque a forma de minerar a forma como
isso tudo tem acontecido é para colocar
os lucros acima da vida dessas pessoas
dessas comunidades do ecossistema e
antes mesmo que aconteceu esse Mariana e
se repetir em Brumadinho já tinha
acontecido os rompimentos em Minas
Gerais e hoje existem 19 barragens que
estão em risco de rompimento em Minas
Gerais não só 19 nós temos 26 mil
barragens no Brasil
714 dessas barragens só de mineração em
Minas Gerais e apenas três por cento
dessas barragens são vistoriados então
eu tô dizendo para vocês que não são só
as barragens lá do meu estado são os
barracos que estão espalhadas pelo
Brasil inteiro
e ninguém cuidando não tem ninguém se
responsabilizando por tudo isso que tem
nos acontecido e eu tô aqui para dizer
que outros rompimentos vão acontecer
outras pessoas não se de mim disseram
isso até que aconteceu Brumadinho até
que aconteceu Mariana e eu tô aqui pra
revelar essas vozes para dizer para
vocês que essas pessoas não vão deixar
de lutar que elas não vão deixar de
Resistir e de gritar para o mundo todo
que tá acontecendo aqui e que vai
continuar acontecendo porque nós não
tomamos Nenhuma medida para impedir que
todas essas tragédias continuem nos
acontecendo essas pessoas resistem elas
estão organizadas tem um movimento dos
atingidos por barragens que está no
Brasil há 30 anos e poucas pessoas
conhecem mas que estão fazendo a luta no
território para que nenhuma dessas
outras tragédias que estão previstas
premeditados que acontecer aconteçam e
uma outra coisa que eu queria dizer para
vocês É que eu queria pedir na verdade
todos vocês eu vi sim se olhasse
cuidassem da Serra de vocês cuidasse do
território onde vocês estão porque
outras tá já estão para acontecer e eu
não queria pedir um minuto de silêncio
porque eu acho que isso
não vai trazer de volta à vida dessas
pessoas eu só queria pedir para vocês
uma vida inteira de luta e de
resistência
somos todos atingidos todos vocês são
atingidos também é
[Aplausos]